ich möchte kurz beginnen mit dem
Rückblick vielleicht erinnern sich
manche noch als Ende Februar Putin
angefangen hat in die Ukraine
einzumarschieren es war ein großer
Schockzustand im Land und es war sofort
klar das wird auch was mit unserer
Energieversorgung machen erobert Habeck
wurde da vier Tage danach von der ARD
Journalistin gefragt ob wir denn nicht
auch noch mal den deutschen Atomausstieg
überdenken müssten weil zu dem Zeitpunkt
waren gerade drei Kernkraftwerke frisch
abgestellt drei liefen noch die sollten
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt jetzt Ende des
Jahres abgeschaltet werden und habe
gesagt zum überraschen dieser dieser
Journalistin in die Kameras es gebe da
keine denkt Tabus und er sagte er würde
diese Frage prüfen und sie nicht
ideologisch abwehren der Verdacht dass
die Grünen diese ideologisch ohne
ideologische Prüfung ernst nehmen war
ungefähr so glaubwürdig wie wenn die
metzgerinnung versprochen hätte wir
prüfen den Vorteil der veganen
Ernährungsweise